all right Kelly yes Kelly where'd you
grow up were you from originally
um Los Angeles I mainly grew up on the
east side and more so and like foster
care different cities but mostly LA I
was born in LA my first time ever going
foster care I was about two months and
it was because my mother had called DCFS
on herself for abusing me I was told it
was postpartum depression on top of her
already on coal service desire so she
called child services on herself because
she would like abuse me my grandma told
me stories how she would abuse me as a
baby like I have pictures of me with
black guys in two months you know and so
basically I got that's the first time I
ever got took away at two months and
then I got my grandma got me but I was
still in the system she got me system
wise it was pretty bad but at the same
time like I was always the type of
person that tried to make like you know
I like to laugh a lot I laughed a lot
but I met my childhood was pretty tragic
I've been I've been abused I've been
raped I've been molested I've been
tortured my first time ever being raped
I was five
my foster parent he raped me and hid in
the foster mom she knew but she never
like she never she didn't care she or
that's what it looked like that got
proven in court me getting molested and
raped at five and then I got moved I've
been in I've been in 24 different foster
homes and my grandma got me at two
months and Foster and foster then she
lost me I think I was around two so I
was in foster care then my mom got me
back she won me back and then she lost
me again due to abuse she abused me
again and and she lost me I had a web
severy where like everywhere purple eps
everywhere and then I got took away
that's when I was in foster care and my
first time ever getting molested at
least to my memory that's the first
recollection recollection I can remember
and it's crazy with that recollection
because that was something that I always
will remember or think that I know
exactly what happened I will always
think certain things to myself like just
on that particular age I would think
like cuz I know exactly what he did to
me I remember him coming in the door I
remember everything
me and my foster mom were just watching
a movie he walked in drunk he had a cup
of alcohol in his hand and
you know he pretty much like asked me to
come into the room or whatever and with
me being five years old you know I'm not
expecting this or whatever so like he
just grabbed me up and like covered my
face and told me to be quiet and just
did it and it was just like blood
everywhere I was screaming she came in
this is how the police was called she
came in and she was like what are you
doing what are you doing he hit her but
I guess I found out later that they had
already history of abuse problems in
their relationship so this is why she
never cared about him continuing to do
it
but like I said I will have memories in
my head of certain things as I'm getting
older and I'm like why would I think
these things if it didn't happen you
know so then I went back and asked my
foster my foster the caseworker and she
explained to me that all of this stuff
was actually documented and stuff like
that and it's just crazy he's like five
years old
getting another foster home and I was
good a few of my foster homes were good
but then I would go to and it'll be
another foster parent that likes to you
know rape and molestin what I don't know
if you could see these on my sides but
my foster dad he actually duct-taped me
to a chair and he pretty he pretty much
screwed Drive screws in my ear and
then he put them out and like screws he
and the you know the small ones he
screwed them with a screw gun he screwed
them with a screw gun and not all the
way in but he's just a sick back he
screwed them in my ears and now I have
permanent marks here they've been here
ever since he did this he duct-taped me
to a chair duct-taped me to a chair I
was sitting in a wooden chair like this
and he duct-taped me he used to chase me
around the house to raped me and hice to
be running around the house then he
would lock his wife in the room and and
she would chased me around the house I
would be screaming for and saying he's
my foster dad yes my foster dad he would
chased me around the house to rape me
and I would just scream and I would cry
he would all it he would always catch me
she never after that one time she tried
and and he hit her after that that's
when she just started getting a lot
rocked in the room and like one day he
raped me so bad that I woke I would
never forget I had on the Hannah Montana
gown and he raped me on the bathroom
floor and to the point where I passed
out I woke up I when I woke up I was in
the bathroom by myself with a puddle of
blood a whole puddle of blood
seven years old
I'm afraid to ask for it really like
going for seven years old after that I
think I went to a lady and they're
pretty much done that's one of the more
so abuse started happening more and more
abuses like physical and verbal abuse
you know it's like I will always say I
want my mom I want my mom
oh I went back to my mom but I did go to
a foster parent who she would like
verbally and physically abused me she I
was out with my mom she would hit me and
saying you're never going back to your
mom and then I went back with my mom
because she completed all of the classes
and stuff like that I went back with my
mom and then she abused me again like
but she it was years past because I
didn't get tooken away till I was like
what ten and she abused me again but she
had already been amusing me throughout
that time but not not loud enough to the
point where the police are being called
like I just thought my mom would make me
wear turtlenecks even if it was hot I
would have to wear a turtlenecks and I
would have to wear long pants long pants
long socks everything will have to be
covered when I go to school because I
will have lips and stepmom like these
scars on my face around my eyes and
stuff my mom she threw a remote at my
eye when I was young and it cut my eye -
the problem I had to go get stitches she
would she pushed me into a glass table
and it broke I got a cut on my iPhone
that - I'm not sure which I it is I
would have to look what is my my mom she
has a mental problem so I've always just
been in the system and I've had they're
not not only it's a lot a lot
so eventually you I ran away I just ran
away because I got sick of it felt like
they weren't doing anything 11 you ready
yeah
I just ran away I was that's when I
started prostituting actually a guy I
met a guy and he and he showed me that
he showed me that like I was running
away and he founded me and then he
started like having sex with me and
stuff and then he just showed me to
prostitute
and ever since I was like 11 until even
now I prostitute cuz I don't have a job
and nobody will hire me I don't have my
high school diploma I don't have any
family like I started doing cocaine at
11 - he showed me cocaine I stopped
doing cocaine though because that's why
I'm so small now I recently as I read I
just did cocaine but I started
prostituting at eleven I've been raped
I'm on the plate
I've been raped on the blade I've been
had a gun put up to my head on the blade
he tried to kill he used to abuse me if
I didn't want to go because when I first
did it it was kind of like fun to me
but then when I did I didn't know that
there was a such thing as different
sizes to penis so you know when it gets
bigger and I don't know I'm 11
I don't know these things they hurt you
know my body hurts my everything is
hurting and stuff like that
they're actually doing it hard they were
they were doing it hard to me like and I
will tell him like I don't want to do it
and he will beat me like beat me to the
point where like my tooth is chipped
hear from him
beating me he's Jimmy
he was my pen that's what that's what he
he told me not now we I stopped messing
with him I want to say earlier this year
I was with him all this time he would
abuse who makes me go on the blade 21 so
not too long ago that I stopped messing
with him I had to run away from him
because and he wanted to he took me like
state to state and so he took me to
another country is it is Mexico
considered another country and that's
[ __ ] up that I even have to ask you
that because I didn't get a lot of
schooling so you know he took me to
Mexico and this guy he Mexican guy he
raped me and he came inside of me and I
got pregnant he told me not for that
puts that one it was time he regulated
all of the everything he regulated if it
was a condom or no condom he talked to
the guys I didn't talk to the guys so I
got pregnant and I went full time with
the pregnancy and it then maybe he died
in some way somehow that what
I thought I was going to have the baby
but it was a stillbirth a stillbirth the
baby was dead and so that's really what
made me you know we leave him because
that was recent that I had a stillbirth
and that I was raped by that Mexican guy
in Mexico so that really [ __ ] me up
because it's like you know I'm and now I
came to skid row
mm-hmm I stay in a tent out here because
I don't want and I'm scared he's gonna
find me are you using a dress I I tried
the cookie
crystal but I really don't want to do it
cuz I don't want to [ __ ] myself up
but I'm more so starting back on cocaine
but I did try just recently tried
crystal - it's crazy that [ __ ] makes you
I was walking around the street naked
finally refresh right there they had to
the police came they got me I went to
Joe for that thank you I know I was high
off crystal and and it was my first time
doing it I went to Joe and I got a DEA
reject but I will still went to Joe for
I still on my record that's what I don't
have anybody nobody but God I don't have
anybody
that's why I have to sell pasta too so
forget to get buy-in on the county
that's all I have is the county and my
[ __ ] tip and God but in tricks that's
all I have
nobody cares about me nobody loves me
nobody checks on me nobody calls my
government phone I don't know who the
[ __ ] my dad is I don't know my dad's
family I don't know I just try to be
strong cuz and I'm just trying to get it
together because I don't want to be out
here for the rest of my life
I really don't I've been through too
much I just cut myself I stop cutting
myself because I was just like I have to
be strong
I cut myself so bad right here to the
point where like and right here I almost
died I want to say a couple of months
ago
and they took me to a psych ward for it
and I was in a psych ward for like a
month and they were prescribing me pills
it was their necks for anxiety their
prescribing me like just a lot of the
next to make me sleep in seroquel and
anger anger drugs because like I get
really angry
I got specimen that's one thing I get
really really really angry and I don't
know how to control myself cuz I feel
like why the and I try to kill myself
because I feel like it's no point of me
being here if I don't have anybody I
want to go to school I want to learn
more I want to I want to be a lawyer I
want to do cosmetology but I don't know
if I can because I haven't been in
school since I was 11 10 you never been
in high school that's so embarrassing
they say no
I've never been in high school at all I
noticed the streets I got put on
gangbang in prostitution that's really
all I know and stealing stealing what I
mean I would never rob somebody out I
was just he wrote that he was my pimp he
would just make me go sell my stuff but
it when I ran away from him i would go
steal some stuff and prostituting up to
more some more so still stuff but he
will always find me and police I always
have time I see the police I run cuz
like you said I look young so just
imagine how young I looked when I was 11
12 13 14 I mean I always had to run from
the police like when he took me to
Mexico I was in the trunk the whole time
in the trunk
I couldn't even ride it in the car you
don't want any police to pull over and
see me okay so I tried to kill myself
yesterday right I checked I took a whole
bunch of Xanax pills cuz I get them
prescribed to me every month
from being in the psych ward I get
prescribed them I tried to and I took a
whole bunch of pills and he the only
reason why I'm here I'm pretty [ __ ] up
because it's Christmastime and and I
don't have anybody like nobody so I just
wanted to kill myself and he made me
throw up all of the pills like all of
them he gagged to me gagging until I
threw up all of the pills so just
imagine if he wouldn't have came in when
he came in I wouldn't even be here today
yeah
if he wouldn't have been that came in
when he came in I would have died I
wouldn't be here to even tell you my
story like that that was that was
weighing heavy on my heart the fact that
I'm here today I thought what am I here
for nobody loves me nobody cares about
me nobody like I told you nobody checks
on me nobody does anything for me I have
often selling my vagina since I was 11
years old
and before that I got raped
treacherously molested treacherously
abused tortured treacherously my I don't
even like to show my body to him because
my foster dad the one that raped first
started raping me he made you know he
made me shave my vagina when I didn't
even have pubic hair to the penny what
cut me cut me cut me so now my mother
I have I had to go to and it's
documented I had to get stitches all in
my vagina because he would be uninsured
when he was raping me and he would he
would cut me so that's why there was a
puddle of blood because he had to cut me
with the razor all up cut me all up cut
me all up and now and I had to go get
futures for that on my vagina at a young
age I had to get my vagina stitched
and now my vagina is damaged because of
what he did to me at a young age and now
I can I don't even feel comfortable
showing anybody in my body my lower body
I hate myself
because of everything that I've been
doing I just feel like what I'll
probably try to kill myself today
especially probably tomorrow because
tomorrow's Christmas and I don't have
anybody I'm not even gonna get to eat
any food all right Christmas dinner
yeah what time I'll be here 2 p.m. ok
here you tell me you show me where your
tent ok we'll figure out a place to me
ok ok I'll try any reason this is in
that place
nice I want some cooler okay
you promise I promise okay okay okay I'm
good but I tell you I'm gonna be here
it's gonna rain tomorrow I'm gonna be
here okay yeah I definitely want to come
back and finish telling ya I think you
probably got a lot more to share
yeah I'll see you okay I'll see you
tomorrow I - here - right here
okay okay okay thank you
no problem